sean comme on fasse une interview
dernier coup dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de tête dans mon dernier
match de football chez pas content quand
ça remonte parce que j'ai initiatique en
ce moment donc ça fait un moment que je
joue au ballon
dernier coup de coeur et coups de coeur
pour moi forme actuelle qui je viens
d'avoir un enfant la sciatique dont tu
parlais ça vient de là aussi bien les
coups de poing ça ne m en même temps que
le coup de tête mais dernier coup de
folie
je me suis acheté un appartement ah oui
ouais tu t'en vous rejoignons bien j'ai
vécu 37 ans à saint denis si tu me vois
la promo donné j'ai eu l'occasion
d'acheter ma part ça servirait de fer
était ou là je suis dans le neuf de ses
biens c'est plus chic and up toile mais
il ya les gens du 9-3 qui vont siffler
mais c'est pas très loin tu prends les
ics est fait pour un flash étaient
assemblés et après versailles après là
je sais pas peut-être vers les coups de
foudre
moi je te les dites à leurs jeux flash
c'est ma femme il ya des coups de gueule
dernier coup de gueule je crois que
c'est écrit dans c'est mal barré
ouais dernier coup de fil
tout à l'heure un est potes là dans la
neige ouais pour lui dire je passais à
ton émission destination n'a pas
l'occasion de passer souvent à la télé
donc c'est ça leur fait plaisir quand on
est là dans les coups de soleil
la dernière fois je suis allé en
vacances les a vus montant il est pas
très bronzée donc moi des fois un rayon
de soleil c'est le pain est directe il
ya plus de soleil dans le 9 2 que dans
les rangs ça dépend de l'altitude la
kryte alif galles et coup de bol et coup
de bol je suis rentré deuxième l'eurotop
hines et possède un petit coup de barre
dans les coups de blues
j'ai perdu les 10 oui ça doit être
celui-là
un dernier coup de rein à ya pas
longtemps non plus ouais ouais malgré la
sciatique on se débrouille